i want to start by telling you two
things about myself before i get into
the full talk
and the first is that i've been writing
about manners and civility for more than
20 years
as a book author and as a magazine
columnist
the second is
my friends know to be very wary of
inviting me over for dinner
because any faux pas that happens at the
table is likely to wind up in print
so i'm watching i can see back there and
i can see through the portals too
so speaking of dinner parties i want to
take you back to 2015 and a dinner party
that i went to
to place this in time this was when
caitlyn jenner
was first coming out shedding her
identity as a kardashian and moving into
her life as a transgender activist
i wrote a common people magazine at the
time talking about the importance of
names and how names are our identity
and that to misuse them or not to use
them erases us in a certain way and
especially with caitlyn jenner i talked
about
caitlyn but also the use of her pronouns
her pronouns
so i'm at this dinner delicious
wonderful fun when my host
goes on a rant
about caitlyn jenner
and
she is saying that it is disrespectful
for caitlyn jenner to force her
to use a new name and to use these new
pronouns
she's not but she's not buying it and
i'm listening and
because i do meditation i took my sacred
pause before i responded
and i reminded her that when she got
married she changed her name and that
she took the name of her husband and
that's the name all of us now use
we don't use it just because it's her
legal name but we use it because it's
respectful
ditto for ms jenner
she didn't buy it and we didn't speak
for years
so
i am known as the civilist and it's
probably a word that you're not that
familiar with
it's not uncommon common parlance and it
comes from the latin and the french
and it means an individual
who tries to live by a moral code who is
striving to be a good citizen
the word civility is derived from adam
that and the original definition of
civility is citizens willing to give of
themselves for the good of the city for
the good of the commonwealth the larger
good
so in this talk you're going to learn
three new ways to be civil i hope
and
it'll be according to the original
definition of civility
my first problem is
civility is an obsolete word
my second problem is
civility has become a dirty word in this
country
and that is whether you lean right or
whether you lean left
and in part that's because modern usage
equates civility with decorum
with formal politeness formal behavior
we've gotten away from the idea of
citizenship
so
let me start by talking a little bit
about my friends on the right who have
conflated civility with what they call
political correctness
and to them call outs for civility are
really very much like what george orwell
wrote in 1984 he called it newspeak
and this was an attempt to change the
way we talk by forcibly changing the
language that we use to change our ideas
by changing the meaning of words
and i think you know my my dinner host
might have had some of that um rattling
around there
uh
and i first personally understood though
the rights problem with civility when i
wrote a column about then candidate
donald trump
and he had just said
he did not have time for total political
correctness and he did not believe the
country did either and uh you know i
took that to heart
uh it was very the audience was very
engaged about that online as you can
imagine there were thousands there's a
thousand responses and this one stood
out to me
because it was representative
political correctness is a pathological
system that lets liberals dominate a
conversation
label demonize and shout down the
opposition
so
i think to the right civility translates
into censure
so that's the right
now my friends on the left also have a
problem with it
and for example there have been those
who have harassed trump administration
officials
who support the president's border wall
they've been called out as rude they've
been called out as nasty they've been
called out as worth
and after one such incident last year
even the washington post you know
left-leaning washington post wrote an
editorial and sided with decorum
and they argued that officials should be
allowed to dine in peace
you know
the wall is the real incivility here the
tear gassing of kids the separation of
families
that's what the protesters say
and imagine if we had sided in this
country with decorum
and courtesy throughout our history you
know i think about the suffragettes
they marched
they picketed it
they were chastised they were arrested
for pursuing the vote for women in the
1920s
you know i also think about the reverend
martin luther king jr
the father of american non-violent civil
disobedience
he was labeled as uncivil in his
attempts to promote racial and economic
justice
so i think you get a sense of
why civility has become a problem a
dirty word here
now
does this mean we can't disagree that we
can't speak our minds
absolutely not
i recently spoke with dr carolyn
lukensmeyer she's kind of the guru of
civility in in this country and the
executive director of a body called the
national institute for civil discourse
and she told me civility does not mean
appeasement or avoiding important
differences it means listening and
talking about those differences with
respect
in a healthy democracy
we need to do that and i call that
respectful engagement
but civil discourse also needs rules it
needs boundaries
for instance there's there's a
difference between language that is
simply rude or demeaning
and speech that invokes hatred and
intolerance and specifically of of
groups and i'm thinking of racial and
ethnic groups i'm thinking of the lgbtq
community i'm thinking of the disabled
we snowflakes call this speech hate
speech
and hate speech can lead to violence
so to that point in the fall of 2018 i
wrote a column about dr christine blasey
ford
you may remember her
she was one of the women who accused
supreme court nominee brett kavanaugh of
sexual assault
and among the responses i received this
message personal message
which you can see here on the slide it's
been largely redacted
this message was 50 words long 10 of
them were of the f-bomb
and the democrats were called out
president obama was called out and i was
referred to in a pretty darn vulgar and
course way
there was an explicit threat in that
message and that is why my editors at
the post sent it to authorities
this came shortly before the pipe bombs
were sent to other media outlets so
everybody was was really kind of on
guard there
and the larger context was only a few
months before
five staffers had been killed at a
maryland newspaper they had been shot
dead
by a reader with a grudge
shut up or else
and it was around that same time
that a different reader of mine started
stalking me online and at first it was
um
i'll call it light and fluffy it was
around this time last year and i still
had my christmas decorations up and
he sent me a message saying you should
take your christmas decorations down
and then he uh noticed that my dog was
off leash one day and then he commented
that i'd gone to the to the market
and then he wrote me one that said
if anyone were to shoot and kill you
it would not be a loss at all
i wish that were the end of the story
because then a few months later he came
to my door my front door in a rage and
tried to break the door down
i now own mace
security system
and a louisville slugger baseball bat
shut up or else
so what's to be done to forestall
civility from turning ugly from turning
violent
my first rule is to de-escalate language
and i've stopped using trigger words
in print
and by trigger words i mean homophobe i
mean racist i mean xenophobe i mean
sexist all of those words
they set people off
they're incendiary and they do not allow
us to find common ground they do not
allow us to find a common heart
and so to this point when john mccain
died in 2018
his supporters noted that he never made
personal attacks but his opponents
agreed as well and i thought that was
what was really noteworthy he challenged
people's policies he challenged their
positions but he never made it personal
and so that's the second rule
so the problem of civility is not only
an american one
in the netherlands there are calls for
civility offensive right now
and as one dutch philosopher has put it
the country has fallen under a spell of
verhuftering
now this is not a word that i knew
before and i did quite a bit of research
it loosely means bullying and the
disappearance of good manners it
actually means much worse than that but
that's what i'm saying here
when you have a specific word though to
describe a problem like that you know
you really have a problem
and in the united kingdom the 2000
brexit vote
you know has divided a nation you know
even more so
and uh one critic of the breakup called
those who favor it
i just love this phrase
the frightened parochial lizard brain of
britain
that's personal
and it makes me miss downton abbey
and it's patina of civility
but therein lies the third rule
don't mistake decorum for civility
even if you have a dowager countess as
fabulous as day maggie smith
[Music]
so let me end with one last story
not that long ago i was at a bakery and
they make these amazing scones
it's a long line there are a lot of
scones
and one by one the scones were
disappearing until there was one woman
in between me and that last scone
praise the lord she said i'll have a
croissant
so when it became my turn i said i'll
take that scone
there's a guy behind me
never had i never turned around never
seen him uh he shouted that's my scone
i've been waiting in line 20 minutes and
uh
i was like
who are you i've been waiting in line 20
minutes and you're behind me
so
i just say i grew up here in new york i
went high school not that far
from here and
i may seem you know very civil here and
so on but i can hip check
anybody for taxi cab in this room on
these streets so i was surprised when i
said to this guy
would you like half
i didn't think about it it just came out
and then he he was very puzzled and i
could see his face change and he said to
me well how about if i buy another
pastry and we'll share both of them
and
he did and we did
and we sat and talked
we had nothing in common
we had nothing in common nationality
sexual orientation occupation
but through this moment of kindness
through this moment of connection
we developed a friendship we have stayed
in touch
although he was appalled to learn that
i'm called the civilist after that but
but i call this the joy of civility the
joy of civility and it led me to wonder
you know what is the good we forego not
just the trouble we avoid when we choose
to be uncivil
and by good i mean friendship i mean
connection i mean sharing a thousand
calories
but i also mean in a larger way you know
as communities and as a country and as a
world what are we missing out on
so today we are engaged in a great civil
war of ideas and identity and we have no
rules for them
you know there are rules for war
think about the geneva conventions they
ensure that every soldier is treated
humanely on and off the battlefield
so frankly i think we need a geneva
convention of civility to set the rules
for discourse for the parameters of that
to help us become better citizens of our
communities and of our countries
and if i have anything to say about it i
would base those rules on the original
definition of civility from the latin
and from the french
civility
citizens willing to give of themselves
for the greater good
for the good of the city
so i think civility with that
understanding is not a dirty word
and i hope
the civilist will not become will not
stay obsolete
thank you